le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
les abeilles participe à l'équilibré
environnemental de la planète sans elle
la pollinisation des espèces végétales
ne pourrait pas se faire
mais ces insectes font aujourd'hui face
à une menace planétaire
le varois ce parasite décime les ruches
et causent de gros dégâts écologiques et
économiques
jusqu'ici épargnée la réunion est
désormais touché par le fléau
[Musique]
voilà on va rentrer dans le d'enrichir
la colle à la ruche et contrôler un
petit peu la ruche
depuis quelques mois les abeilles du
jardin botanique de mascarin sont sous
haute surveillance un bol avec ses
collections d'arbres et de fleurs
le site est un lieu idéal pour la
prolifération des insectes
un rucher pédagogique a été créé pour
sensibiliser le grand public au rôle
primordial de la bei dans la
préservation de la nature
on a des floraisons à la fois des
espèces indigènes mais en fonction des
collections botaniques que l'on a dit
qu'on a aussi des fruitiers on a des
cactus des plantes grasses donc on va
avoir des floraisons tout au long de
l'année et donc des abeilles qui vont
aller d'arbre en arbre de collections
botaniques en collections botaniques
mais ce sanctuaire est aujourd'hui
menacé l'ennemi un acarien parasite à
l'origine d'une hécatombe planétaire
chez les abeilles le varois
le varois donc on va le voir là dedans
la dans la colonie c'est un petit
acarien qui mesurent sur son axe le plus
long 2 mm olivier et vétérinaire il va
vérifier si le parasite est présent dans
les ruches j'utilise un petit contenant
donc qu'à une grille dans laquelle je
vais mettre du sucre glace et en fait on
va mettre dedans 301 bay on va secouer
les abeilles pendant entre 45 secondes
et une minute
donc normalement on a bien décroché le
varois et donc c'est cette petite
bestiole et là on voit qu'il ya beaucoup
la csé c'est extrêmement fait infectés
jusqu'à maintenant la réunion faisait
partie des rares territoires encore
épargnée par le fléau
mais le 4 mai dernier le varois est
détectée dans un rucher de saint denis
quelques l'heure d'été a tous pu
récupérer roland fait pour toujours
benoît est apiculteur depuis 31 ans
pour lui comme pour ses collègues
l'arrivée du varois est un coup de
massue
nous on n'a pas eu d'enfants
c'est un virus et une passion avant tout
la bei cadier jours on peut gagner de
l'argent ne fait pas c'est un état
d'esprit aussi l'agriculture
et puis c'est pas que produire du miel
nous la situation a de quoi inquiéter le
varois a fait des ravages dans plusieurs
pays
mais à la réunion les conséquences
pourraient être encore plus grave car
nos abeilles sont d'une espèce
spécifique à la zone
il faut savoir que lorsque varois arrive
sur l'intérêt grand nouveau en général
on perd là où il arrive il va faire
disparaître 80 80 90 % du cheptel
lorsque les territoires intimes ans 1
comme l'europe ou l'amérique ou même
madagascar où l'afrique
donc il peut y avoir une possibilité
qu'ils avaient ils reviennent mais sur
un petit territoire comme le nôtre
ainsi on perd 90 % de nos abeilles on va
perdre le patrimoine génétique de notre
abeilles surtout que notre abeilles et
indigènes donc c'est aussi un enjeu
patrimonial le milieu apicole s'est
rapidement mobilisée pour éradiquer la
menace des traitements sont placés dans
tous les ruchers attaqué par le parasite
donc ça c'est un traitement
conventionnel et et qu'on va glisser
dans les espaces dans les inter cadre
les abeilles vont passer dessus et en
fait c'est bon sens du rire du produit
qui va qui va tuer le varois est en fait
tous les varois qui sont dans la colonie
à côté des abeilles vont
vont pouvoir être traitées puis 1,6
ainsi tomber et puis arrêtez de se
reproduire
à l'issue du traitement il ya plus de
voix roi dans la colonie le financement
de ce traitement fait partie des mesures
d'urgence que le département a mis en
place le conseil départemental est
intervenu auprès du gds en accordant une
subvention de 172 milles euros pour
d'abord éradiquer les premiers ruchers
qui était complètement infestés nous
avons également refinancer l'étude
diagnostique pour savoir où est ce qu
était le varois sur l'ensemble du
territoire de l'île de la réunion
et puis enfin nous avons aussi financer
le traitement porté par le groupement de
défense sanitaire qu'est le gds le
département a répondu présent et nous
allons bien sûr poursuivre cet
accompagnement et faire en sorte que
nous puissions préserver l'essentiel et
garder nos ruchers à la réunion la
production de miel avoisine les 150
tonnes par an en 2006 les pesticides
utilisés pour lutter contre le
chikungunya avait déjà menacé les
abeilles
aujourd'hui le monde avicole fait
peut-être face un danger encore plus
important
[Musique]
le varois est un acarien parasite qui
s'attaquent aux abeilles
il peut détruire jusqu'à 90% de la
colonie infectés et s'est répandue
partout dans le monde
les symptômes sont une mortalité
importante malgré des réserves de miel
et pollen l'apparition de jeunes
abeilles déformé à couvin irréguliers ou
encore l'abandon des ruches en cas
d'apparition ou de doute quant à la
présence du varois contacter
immédiatement la daf par mail à
l'adresse alimentation point d a à f 9 7
@ agriculture.gouv.fr ou par téléphone
au 02 62 33 36 61
[Musique]